hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job every episode to
deconstruct world-class performers from
all different disciplines all different
worlds
my guest today a fan favorite is seth
godin you can find him on twitter at
this is seth's blog
seth is the author of 19 international
bestsellers translated into more than 35
languages
can't wait until he has his 20th that'll
make that number so much cleaner
including tribes purple cow lynchpin the
dip and this is marketing he writes
daily at
seth's dot blog which is one of the most
popular blogs in the world and has been
for god decades i would imagine at this
point he's
also the founder of the alt mba in the
akimbo workshops online seminars that
have transformed the work of thousands
of people
he writes about the post-industrial
revolution the ways ideas spread
marketing quitting leadership and most
of all changing
everything his newest book is the
practice subtitle
shipping creative work you can find him
online
at seth's dot blog or sethgoden.com he's
on twitter but he's not an active
tweeter
you can find that at this is seth's blog
and
on instagram handled by his team at seth
godin
this episode is brought to you by
pornhub just kidding
this episode is brought to you by four
sigmatic which
is part of my morning routine also part
of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are
a number of ways that i use for sigmatic
in the mornings i regularly start with
their mushroom coffee instead of regular
coffee
and it doesn't taste like mushroom let
me explain this first of all
zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee
it's easy on my stomach tastes amazing
and all you have to do
is add hot water i use travel packets
i've been to probably a dozen countries
with
various products from four sigmatic and
their mushroom coffee
is top of the list that's number one i
travel with it
i recommend it i give it to my employees
i give it to house guests
so if you're one of the sixty percent of
americans or more who drink coffee daily
consider switching it up this stuff is
amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive enhancement side
easy on the system side energizing side
the next is actually their chaga tea
which tastes delicious it is
decaf completely decaf and some may
recognize
chaga it is nicknamed the king of the
mushrooms it is excellent for
immune system support so needless to say
i'm focused on that right now myself and
so i will often have that
in the afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself
sane cordyceps excellent for endurance
they have a whole slew of options that
you can check out
every single batch is third party lab
tested for heavy metals
allergens all the bad stuff to make sure
that what gets into your hands
is what you want to put in your mouth
and they always offer
a 100 percent money back guarantee so
you can try risk-free
why not i've worked out an exclusive
offer with four sigmatic on their
best-selling lions main coffee i
literally have a mug
full of it in front of me right now and
this is just for you my dear podcast
listeners receive
up to 39 off i don't know how we arrived
at 39
but 39 off it's a lot they're best
selling lions main coffee bundles to
claim this deal you must go to four
4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available
on their regular website go to four
sigmatic that's f o u r
s i g m a t i c dot com
tim to get yourself some awesome and
delicious mushroom
coffee full discount is applied at
checkout
this episode is brought to you by tonal
t-o-n-a-l
i'm super excited about this one and i
was skeptical
of it in the beginning tonal quote tonal
is the world's most
intelligent home gym and personal
trainer end quote that's the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to tonal by three different
friends
all of them are tech savvy one of them
is a former competitive skier
who's doubled his strength in a number
of movements using tonal even though
he has a long athletic background
and i'll paint a picture for you by
eliminating traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells tonal can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal and
you can dial weights
up and down with the touch of a button
in one pound increments
using magnets and electricity so the
movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm
still getting a tonal installed i've
used tonal for multiple workouts now
to do things i just cannot do in my home
gym
such as the chop and lift exercises from
the four-hour body all sorts of cable
exercises that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then tonal
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that and the other thing
and after one workout
on tonal focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths
grow tonal also has a growing library of
expert-led workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized to your body
using artificial intelligence and other
aspects of
the engineering and smart features check
your form in real time just like a
personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but tritonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www.tonal.com for 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim tonal be your strongest
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
[Music]
seth welcome to the show thank you tim
it's great to talk to you
and i thought we would start where all
good things start and that
is the etymology of the word hack
which you introduced me to so what is
this word hack and what context
would you like to provide oh so many
ways to dig into this so here's the deal
when london was
smaller on the outskirts of london was a
borough called hackney
and hackney was a place where they would
raise horses
they didn't raise thoroughbreds they
didn't raise extraordinary show horses
they raised just average horses average
horses at an average price
and so if you got a hackney horse you
probably did it because you were i don't
know a handsome cab driver
and that's where your nickname came as
being a hack
in that you didn't have a special horse
you simply had a horse
there's nothing wrong with raising a
hack there's nothing wrong
with buying a hack being a hack
is about giving the customer exactly
what they want
at a decent price however
it is important to distinguish it from
the magic
fraught topic of our art of that thing
that
lights us up the work that we actually
want to do
and so my book the practice is about
that gap
between being a hack selling as if
you're a hack
and the other thing which is the
generous act of doing something
magic of leading and it really bothers
some people to hear their work described
as hack work
but i think there's nothing wrong with
it you should own it
because you need to distinguish it from
that other work you can do
now you're talking about something that
bothers other people i want to talk for
a minute or
five about things that bother you so one
of my favorite aspects
of our conversations to give a little
slice of life for people
i picked up a book because i erroneously
thought you had recommended it to me it
came up on the podcast somewhere else i
shan't
name it unless you would like to but i
picked up this book i really loved the
introduction in the first chapter or two
and i prematurely sent a text
to seth implying that i was impressed
with this book he had recommended
and not too far thereafter we had dinner
we sat down and you're like tell me
about this book because i could not
disagree more with everything
in these pages effectively i'm
paraphrasing so i like
how direct you are you do not
mince words when it comes to opinions
that that you formed
and i would love to know what other
commonly used words
or phrases bother you whether it's
the concepts of the words themselves or
how they are wielded right because in
this case you're taking a word hack and
you're
going back to the roots and you're
recontextualizing it and
showing that it can be a neutral or
positive thing not just a
derisive term are there any other
terms phrases concepts that are banded
about that
that bother you well there are a couple
that i find
really useful to question
and one is the way we interchange
learning and education and the other one
is the way we play with the word quality
so i'm happy to start with either one
but quality might make an easier place
to go
let's go to quality okay so quality
if you want to be a perfectionist is a
great way to hide
because you don't want to be an enemy of
quality that
when someone says well i can't ship this
yet because the quality isn't there
when someone says why are you racing
through that don't you want to put
quality into it well we're defenseless
in the face of that and so someone who
doesn't want to ship their work
is going to stand behind perfectionism
but perfectionism has nothing to do with
perfect
and perfect doesn't have a lot to do
with quality so quality has a very
specific definition it comes from
edwards deming
and the rest of the quality movement of
the 40s and 50s the people who gave us
the toyota
and what it means is meets spec
that's it meets spec
and so if i said what's a better quality
car a toyota corolla or a rolls royce
the answer is a toyota because a toyota
meets spec
it more reliably does exactly what it's
supposed to do when it's supposed to do
it
than a rolls-royce does a rolls-royce is
a different thing
it's luxury it's ostentatious
spending of resources to create
something most people can't have
and that's a fine thing too if you want
it and that kind of quality
is also worth chasing if that's what you
wanted
but it's easy to show that high fashion
goods
you know luxury purses things that we
would say have quality
don't actually last as long as something
from rei
so again back to meeting spec then the
third definition of quality
is the magic of magic so
in in the book i talk about the
difference between hamilton and west
side story most people have never seen
them on broadway
uh hamilton is famous because
something changes in a lot of people in
the audience when they see what
lin-manuel built
on the other hand west side story cost a
fortune
the tickets were 400 bucks the
projection screen was the best i'd ever
seen
and nobody remembers what happened on
stage because
the quality of magic wasn't there
what do you mean by magic or how would
you describe that magic to someone
who is in present what what is the magic
so if we go to the colloquial
understanding of magic
someone who does a coin trick where it
disappears from one hand this is gone
for a moment we feel real tension
and it's the tension of that couldn't
happen and
that happened at the same time one
know how the trick is done it's simply a
trick
the magic evaporates and in the case of
great writing great customer service
great theater
the first time you experience it the
unexpected moment
when lights turn on for you i want to
call that
magic so if you've ever been inside of
richard serra
sculpture dear beacon it's a two million
pound piece of steel
if i showed you a sketch of it you
wouldn't get the joke but if you saw
in real life something would change in
you if you understood the genre and what
came before etc
so i believe that now that we've got
a.i and robots and offshoring
and the rest the work that's left for us
is the work to create magic how do you
think
it maybe this is a bad question but
lin-manuel miranda
and his team do that in hamilton
more effectively is it an
unusual combination of elements of
course it is i mean in many respects
i've seen the show what else is there to
that experience or that that piece of
art that product
in in your mind so i was talking to
someone the other day
about this and they were talking about
the fact that they were
eager to make some sort of creative
magic but they were just waiting for a
really good idea
i said you mean a really good idea like
a multi-million dollar broadway musical
based on an
obscure revolutionary war character with
the entire cast played
by people who aren't traditionally cast
in those roles in a soundtrack sort of
based on rap and hip-hop like that kind
of really great idea
not a really great idea right and
it doesn't work because when you read
the paragraph about it or even if you
read churno's book
it was obvious that this was a good idea
it's a good idea
because it is a series of moments that
create
tension and then relieve it it is based
on a mixing of several genres by someone
who
really truly understands them so the
things that happen in hamilton
um rhyme with the things that came
before
if you're a fan of broadway you notice
things that fit in
even though you're surprised that they
do if you're a fan
of rapper hip-hop you notice things that
fit in even though you might be
surprised that they do he makes
references in every single line to
some giant who came before and so that
texture grabs people who have
cultural awareness and then he takes you
every few minutes to a place
where you're not sure it's going to work
and then he relieves the tension and
starts the process over again
and it's easy to hear this rant and
think well that only happens in a good
broadway show
but i would argue it happens at a fine
restaurant
dinner that you're going to remember and
it can also happen
at a business meeting because we're
humans
and that's the roller coaster that
informs how we remember the world
you described just moments ago
how people can hide behind the word
quality or use it as a means
of postponing action right it's a bit of
a
unfair trump card that can be used
really effectively
to not engage right to not take take
risk there's a i want to say a corollary
of sorts to that that i wouldn't
mind i wouldn't mind i would like if you
could just
reiterate for folks we've spoken about
it before and that is
kind of hiding behind the big hiding
behind
creating something gigantic or affecting
a billion people etc could you speak to
that because i think this is
this is closely related and then i have
a follow-up completely related you know
we live
in a crazy moment in time and we're also
in political season and part of it is
where is the person on a white horse and
shining armor
who's going to come fix everything and
if we read
the traditional business media the folks
who are lionized
are running public companies changing
the fabric of our culture
racking up billions and billions of
dollars as if that's the only sort of
success
that matters and you almost never read a
story
about a kindergarten teacher like lenny
levine who changed the lives of 20 kids
by showing up day after day you can't
say you can't play
and now 20 25 years later after lenny
has passed away those kids are passing
on that message
to other kids but we don't write
articles about that and
one of the things i've been arguing is
that the smallest viable audience
is more attainable than ever before that
it didn't used to be possible
as kevin kelly would talk about a
thousand true fans impossible
but you know if you run an hvac small
business
200 customers is plenty and you know
i am super pleased with how my books
have done but 99
of the people in america have never read
a book i wrote
99 plenty fine the smallest viable
audience means you're on the hook
because if you are specific about who
it's for
then that group gets to say you made me
a promise you didn't keep it
whereas if you say i have this big shiny
idea but this vc won't fund me or this
media company won't write about me
or oprah won't call now you have a great
excuse
[Laughter]
all right so i'm going to personalize
this selfishly because that is my nature
uh to flashback
now i'm going to create a montage of
dinners with seth this is uh this is
just a
portion of our exchange in the last
dinner same dinner where i mistruted
this book to you
as a recommendation where i asked you
for advice
because i was feeling stuck with writing
and you very very uh
observantly replied didn't we talk about
that eight months ago the last time we
had dinner
and i said yes indeed we did it shows
you how little progress i've made
and whether this is just an opportunity
to showcase my insecurities
i don't know but i would love to hear
what you think it is that i torture
myself with or that tortures me
that leads me to ask you
these types of repeated questions on
different occasions because you
are as much as anyone i know you
seem right from the outside looking in
and maybe it's like the calm duck on the
surface kicking like hell underwater i
don't know
you seem to be a relatively unconflicted
person
you're not like biting your nails
fretting about
doing a or b you seem to pretty calmly
do your thing
and i wouldn't describe myself that way
so in what you've seen is there
is there any sort of outside perspective
where you're like i think that these are
some of the reasons tim gets tied up and
nuts
is there anything that you have to okay
well
i'm sorry first of all if i'm making you
miserable dinner i apologize that's
certainly not no no no no you're not no
i love our dinners
so uh i think this is just a segue into
conversation you left out the thing i
said
after i said the thing about eight
months which is
where's your bad writing and
there's no such thing as writer's block
writer's block is real but it does not
exist
what it really is is misnamed i have a
fear of bad writing
i have a fear of what the world will say
when it encounters my bad writing
and the way through is to do your bad
writing
you don't have to ship it to the world
but you have to do the bad writing
and bad writing over time if you do
enough of it
can't persist good writing will slip
through
and i learned this from isaac asimov he
and i worked together on a project
years ago he published 400 books back
when it was hard to publish a book
400 books and he told me that
every morning sorry that's the volunteer
fire department every morning
for six hours he would sit and type and
it didn't matter if it was good or not
he had to do six hours of typing
now obviously he didn't have a typing
problem just about anybody can do six
hours of typing
and then at the end of the shift he
would look throughout the bad writing
whatever was left what was
left and the subconscious understood
that if he's gonna type anyway you might
as well type something good
so he got through the bad writing thing
and
in your case you have so much skill
and such a benefit of the doubt from
people you've earned it from
that it's really likely that you're
saying
why do i need to get back into that
there's nothing but downside for me
because you know how to make one of the
world's best podcasts you do it on the
regular
people really like it when you write a
book they roll their eyes
read the whole thing aren't you proud of
me what a pain in the neck it takes a
year
just do the other thing and so i totally
get that feeling
and this is where we lead to the second
part about being conflicted
and it's it's a small nike riff which is
that just do it we're not going to go
into the origin of that phrase coming
from a mass murderer
but just do it impossible
is this like a manson family reference
gary gilmore
wow i have no idea all right that'll be
for people to
research on their own that was the last
thing he said before they killed him
wow just do it now you'll never be able
to unsee that image sorry
just do it implies what the hell it
doesn't matter
that's not a good way forward because it
pushes you to be
a hack who's not responsible for your
own work
the alternative is to replace the word
just with the word merely
merely do the work that the time you are
spending
narrating yourself doing the work the
time you're spending catastrophizing the
work
is not helping anything and so
i was really insecure
flailing failing entrepreneur for
at least eight years in a row just
consistently failing
barely breaking even getting close to
bankruptcy on a regular basis
and i was willing things to work out
and i was spending a lot of time
dramatizing
all of the perfect problems that i was
confronting
and then i was able to shift to merely
doing the work without the narrative and
without the drama
and as soon as we can merely do the work
then there's room to see what needs to
be seen
so i don't believe in the muse at all i
don't think there's any outside force
i don't think talent really matters i
think what matters
is choosing to find your smallest viable
audience
understand your genre and explore what
it means to make magic in the small
so you can do it again two things the
first
is you are a delightful dinner host and
i
love our dinners so not to cherry pick
and make it
look like a uh sort of okay you're
invited back
to make yeah this is not sort of a
collage video collage of like nascar
accidents that i want to paint as the
experience
at your house that's not not the case at
all number two i would love to
ask about the decision the point at
which you decide you have something
that you would like to publish or share
and that quality
cut off or how you think about it
because in my head
the helpful and self-defeating depending
on how you want to look at it
perfectionist side of things
will for instance look at something i
wrote in 2010
and say i can't do that anymore
and if i practice i could still practice
for weeks
and publish something on the blog and it
would not be that good
therefore i'm not going to publish
because i feel like people will be
disappointed or i'll be letting them
down
and that the attention they'll spend on
it will not derive or
return as much value to them right so
this that's the
voice that is the the deliberation that
i have in my own head
and i do actually have hundreds of
drafts like i have
shitty stuff but it's never quite
crossed the chasm
into good enough to publish so i've been
stymieing myself in that respect and
there is part of me that's like you know
what the podcast is easier it's fun
i feel like it's a craft i'm still
improving on
why don't i just do that there is part
of me that says that then there's
another part that says that's a cop-out
in fact you know the writing helps you
to learn to think
as kevin kelly to invoke that name again
right he writes
to think he doesn't think and then write
and that i'm
shortchanging myself by using
perfectionism as
an out yeah if hearing all of that
what what comes to mind for you well
i'll share my personal experience but
first i want to
challenge something you stated as fact
which is yes
that the writing isn't good enough to
publish
says who this is me right it's
right that's me right so it's not that
the writing isn't good enough to publish
it's that when you look at the writing
your analysis of where you are in the
marketplace and
the promise you'd like to make and keep
doesn't
match the writing that's in front of you
but i dare
say as talented as you are at so many
things
this might not be your best skill
knowing when it's ready to publish
yeah true and it may make sense in this
world where it is
ever easier to hire somebody to
do the thing they are good at to say to
this person
here's 5 000 words aimed at this kind of
reader
tell me where i'm got light and tell me
where i should
take stuff out because the way
you get my friend uh who i went to
business school evan
climbed mount everest back when that was
a very big deal and
i had never seen any i mean there was no
youtube or anything and i was
quizzing him what's that like well he
said
that the first weeks are just spent
walking up this trail that's not that
hard a trail to walk up
with tea houses along the way and stuff
like that
it's only toward the end once you've
committed
to climbing mount everest that mount
everest actually gets really hard to
climb
and it's a fortunate coincidence for the
climbers that it happens in that order
because your sunk costs have increased
so much by the time
that it gets serious that you're too
embarrassed to
turn to your peers and say i can't put
in the work
and so what you're doing before you get
to the hard part is you're inventing a
reason to stop
and you said something that was really
poignant which is you look at stuff you
wrote in 2010
and you say i can't do that anymore well
two things happened to me
first 20 years ago i wrote a book called
permission marketing it became a new
york times bestseller and i said i'm
done
what could i do first time out of the
gate because i had been a book packager
before this is my first quote real book
how could i beat that so i stopped i
just stopped and i sat in the dark
for a year i just didn't do much of
anything
because i said i can't hit lightning
like that again
and thanks to malcolm gladwell he sent
me
he was unknown he sent me this new book
called the tipping point
and he asked me to write a blurb for it
and i read it in one night and realized
that without knowing it i had been
writing a book
about how ideas spread and in the next
12 days
i wrote a 225 page book
and i sent it to malcolm and i said look
if you want me to not publish this
because it
seems like you unlocked the key and i
don't want to take away anything from
the tipping point
i will stop and just throw it out but i
needed to get this out of my system
and he was such a mensch he gave me his
blessing and wrote the forward
and i realized in that moment i couldn't
write permission marketing
again that day was gone but i could
write this book
and someone would benefit from it and
then
10 years later saying 2010 you're saying
i wrote a book called linchpin
and i will never be able to write a book
that good again i will never write a
book that goes that deep
close to my bones that makes me feel
the way that book made me feel and after
that book came out i felt the same way
again
which is well i if this is the
journey i found the end of the journey
and i realized six nine months later
that that was selfish and that leads to
the other
key thing i want to talk about which is
generosity
because generosity doesn't mean free
people pay
for a surgeon who's going to save their
life generosity means
that you're expending emotional energy
emotional labor
to help somebody else and as soon as i
could shift it around in my head
to say somebody over there who could use
a hand
then it wasn't about me anymore and i
wasn't parading anything
and it got way easier to merely do the
work without commentary
because there's somebody over there i'm
doing it for here we go
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the
four-hour body this is more than 10
years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula
on the market it has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex
probiotics and prebiotics for gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i
focus on nutrient-dense meals to begin
with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around and right now
athletic greens is giving my audience
that's you guys
a special offer on top of their
all-in-one formula which is a free
vitamin d supplement with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so particularly in the
winter months adding a vitamin d
supplement to your daily routine is a
great option for additional immune
support
so make an investment in your health
today and try the ultimate all-in-one
wellness bundle
support your immunity gut health and
energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com tim you'll receive up
to a year's supply of vitamin d for free
with your first subscription purchase
again that's athleticgreens.com
tim
you have a great quote in the
introduction
of the new book from sculptor elizabeth
king
and i'd love to hear you explain this
or give examples of how it can apply or
might apply
the quote from elizabeth king is process
saves us from the poverty of our
intentions
what does that mean there would be no
book if it weren't for that quote from
elizabeth king
uh i don't know how it ended up on my
desk it came
from somebody else who took credit for
the quote and i started tracking it down
because it so resonated with me
and after talking to him he acknowledged
well someone else really said it first
and i found this woman and if you close
your eyes and visualize a sculptor you
might be visualizing her
and if you think about how she lives her
life
and the number of hours she puts into
each piece of work
it's extraordinary and they made a
documentary of some of her work which
you can see on amazon
i had never heard of her but now she's
my friend and i've
just learned so much from that one
sentence
what she is saying is this tomorrow
morning
when you wake up you probably won't feel
like engaging in the practice
and if you do you probably won't feel
that way the next day
that what we do is once
decide we decide that we're a runner and
runners go running every day
we decide we're a blogger and bloggers
blog every day
and that decision lightens the cognitive
load
so much because there's no time no
reason
to negotiate with ourselves because we
already had the meeting
we already decided now the question is
not
should we go or not the question is
should we go left or right but we're
going
are there other macro decisions like
that in your life
that you could give as examples of
saving yourself from the poverty of
intentions or from the whimsy
of how you feel on different mornings
well
so the the other one which is as big as
that one
is i think authenticity is a crock and i
think authenticity is overrated and
talked about far too much
the problem with authenticity is it's
selfish
authenticity enables us to say whatever
we want and if people don't like it well
i was just being authentic
it is a ticket to self-absorbed
inconsistency
and i don't think anybody we serve wants
that
i think what they want is consistency i
think they want us to make a promise and
keep it
and the reason it's called work not
my hobby is because i made a promise
and so i decided a really long time ago
that i was going to be consistent and it
didn't matter if in a moment
i felt like yelling at a customer
service person or going up on stage when
i'm supposed to be
adding energy and just taking energy
instead and what i learned from that
is the way we act determines how we feel
way more often than the way we feel
determines how we act
i've heard you well i say i've heard you
i guess
because i know your voice so i hear your
voice when i read you
that do what you love is for amateurs
love what you do is the mantra for
professionals
and i find this interesting on multiple
levels because amateur
the sort of latin root relates to love
so
if if do what you love is for amateurs
then love what you do as for
professionals
we can dig into some layers of that
but i'll add one more thing which is
three words attitudes are skills and
these these these might go together
nicely
like a blt of concepts could you expand
on
any of those okay so let's talk about
skills you've come up first with
wrestling and then with other
skill based activities that you excelled
at
by putting in an enormous amount of
effort
and practice and grit but plenty of
other people did too
and you somehow outperformed them
and you've done that beyond the physical
realm you've done it in
culture and in writing as well i would
argue that because in addition to the
obvious easy to measure hard skills
of how many words per minute can you
type in how many pounds can you bench
press
there are soft skills and they involve
curiosity
they involve experimentation and 30
other things
these are all skills in the sense that
we can learn them
we can learn to be more honest we can
learn to be more diligent we can
learn to be more persistent and that's
great
because if you can learn them then
you're not stuck where you are
you can become who you want to be and so
if we
start by acknowledging that our
attitudes are skills
and that skills are learnable suddenly
talent
recedes far into the rear view mirror
and
we are going to be rewarded not simply
because we can beat someone on a test
but because our whole posture is based
on
the possibility of better and the
possibility of
if your goal is to win to win that's the
second piece
that goes right next to the other skills
and people overlook it
because our industrial system doesn't
really reward us for measuring that
stuff
how do you take something that is
considered an attitude and
convert it into a skill in other words
it seems like you would have to take say
honesty and
i'm not sure if ben franklin did this
particularly well necessarily but as
one of the virtues convert it into some
type of habit or action that you
practice on a regular basis is that the
right way to think about this and
if so how might you approach taking
something
that is widely considered an
attitude or a talent and translate it
into a skill so let's pick being a good
listener and being charismatic
i think perfect most people if they
didn't think about it a lot would say
that those things
are talents those things come naturally
to some people
they're not skills they're sort of
hardwired attitudes is that fair
i think so but we know what makes
someone
be seen as a good listener and what
makes someone be seen
as charismatic and you can do those
things
and at the beginning just like falling
asleep you will be faking it
but then just like falling asleep you
will be doing it
and in the case of being a good listener
it might sound stilted at first
to ask follow-up questions it might
sound
unnatural at first to leave a beat
when you ordinarily would jump in i like
most people don't think of me
as a good listener because i jump in and
other people who i know
don't they leave that extra beat well
that's a skill
and you know whether it's dale carnegie
or anyone who's
followed in his footsteps you can learn
those things
and at first you seem as awkward as
someone who just learned how to ride a
bike
and then you don't got it so
i should also say that just to reinforce
what you're saying
becoming a better listener and that
extra beat
training yourself to utilize that extra
beat is absolutely a practice i remember
cal fussman
who wrote for esquire for ages and ages
and ages
and has interviewed everybody muhammad
ali
i think gorbachev you name it and
his expression is let the silence do the
work
and uh you can remember that and then
apply it it is a
learnable practicable skill are there
any
particular or any other
skills that you think are important for
say entrepreneurs
or creatives that
have a disproportionate roi if a
listener can train themselves to view
them and approach them as skills
i think the combination of patients and
inpatients
most of the struggling entrepreneurs
i've seen are impatient
when it comes to things that look like
an external hustle
they're emailing people too many times
they're looking for a shortcut they've
got an elevator pitch they've got the
fancy business card they're pushing and
pushing
externally that's the wrong place to be
impatient but when it comes to
confronting
the thing they're afraid of they can
just make a really wide berth around it
instead of
figuring out how to be honest looking in
the mirror and saying you know
this isn't that good i should just do
something else the same thing is true
with someone like elizabeth king or a
stand-up comic or richard sarah
if we look yesterday i was listening to
one of the earliest demos of
joni mitchell and i don't think there's
anybody
who wants to argue that joni mitchell
was a hack nor anybody who wants to
argue that she didn't have a huge
contribution to music
but her cover of the house of the rising
sun
it wasn't just that i wasn't familiar
with her version of it it just wasn't
any good
and fortunately she was patient with
herself
she didn't say oh i'm bad at this and
then go work at a 7-eleven
and so where we need patience
is in confronting the things we're going
to get better at
and in strapping in for a useful
journey and where we need impatience is
with our
fear and with our selfishness what about
worrying
what's your perspective on worrying so i
had a riff
a while ago it was one of my most
popular blog posts
and i'm hesitant to dive too deep
because i am not a medical professional
and there are people
who are challenged by organic and
and trauma-related illnesses
but for leaving that group aside anxiety
is experiencing failure in advance at
least it is for me
meaning that after it's over we don't
call it anxiety anymore
we're in grief or we're rebuilding but
when it might go wrong
worrying anxiety is what we feel when
we're imagining it did
and that's not helping anything and so
the question is how do we focus that
part of our
attention on something generous instead
because anxiety and worry is almost
never
in service of someone else it's in
service of our need for the status quo
and reassurance
and i think that reassurance is futile
because you never
have enough of it can you say more about
that please so
it is futile because we can never have
enough of it right so it feels great
to get reassurance um i wish
that you know the phone would ring and
it's the head of the pulitzer committee
saying that they read this thing i wrote
and it's fantastic
i would be high as a kite for at least a
day and a half
and then you'd need it again
because what it did for you was
make you feel for a moment like bad
outcomes weren't going to happen
until you got new evidence that they
might and then you're back to anxiety
and worrying again
so people who get hooked on reassurance
might end up
building an intimacy with the person
who's reassuring them all the time
but it is not helping them do better
work nor is it making them happier
the alternative is to say this might not
work
this thing i did this thing i cared
about might not work odds are it won't
but i have a portfolio and then i'll
make the next thing
because we don't live on the savannah
this is not a matter of life or death
most of the time
it is instead a matter of ego and
self-esteem
and it's not fatal and so all of the
worrying
is worse than the rejection when it
finally comes
so better i think to merely do the work
be generous with the work and improve
our skills
so we can do it again and that gets back
to elizabeth king's quote
you are a fantastic
presenter public speaker teacher
of course these things tie together
although not all good public presenters
are good teachers but you are excellent
at all those things and i remember
advice i was given which i don't follow
as as
as well as many which is presentations
fail
more often from too much information
rather than too little
i think this is true books also and part
of the reason why
as one instance the four hour chef was
such a
incredibly challenging and also
confusing book ultimately something i'm
very proud of but it tried to do
more than any three books should try to
do and it ended up being very
problematic for that reason not from the
writing perspective not so much from the
reader perspective in any case how do
you think about constraints
and can you give any examples
of constraints historical constraints
that you like in your life or applied to
other creatives entrepreneurs anything
okay so it's a two-part question the
first part is about pedagogy
and the thinking about how people learn
and
i think one reason that a lot of people
are bad
at teaching is because they don't think
about pedagogy all they know is they
know something
and if they could just recite all the
things they know someone else will know
it too
and that's not how learning works so the
the challenge that we have
is not seeking information density
and tufty i think made a mistake with
this with his graphs
that trying to cram as much information
in a square inch as we can about
napoleon's
whatever whatever yes someone who's into
that
who's willing to dissect it will find a
marvel
of information inside i look at a book
like the four hour chef
and it's stunning the scope of what you
did
the depth of what you did but it has a
tufty density problem
in that very dense right in that you
were counting on somebody
to go deep into it get inside your head
and
learn what you learned but that's not
how the typical person we seek to serve
learns something that we learn things by
becoming momentarily
incompetent we used to feel like we were
in
control that we understood things and
then all of a sudden a new fact arises
that counters what we know and in that
moment we're
feeling incompetent and that's when most
people quit
but then we get through it and now we
know something more than we used to know
and now we're on to the next thing and
pacing that process
is tricky so you know if you're sitting
listening to a high-level conversation
between
uh two extraordinary systems engineers
they're back and forth and really fast
because
they've got full throttle between them
but
most of the time you don't get that
privilege and so the challenge
is not to dumb it down but to
figure out what are the useful chunks of
tension
that you can create where someone can
feel the tension
get through the tension absorb it and
then be ready for another bit
and media challenges us because every
once in a while something breaks through
that's super dense and like i wish i
could write something that dense i wrote
one book that was that dense
survival is not enough it sold 14 000
copies
um it's hard to get to
where people will sit with you for that
long
um so i'm ranting here but you asked
about boundaries
i appreciate yeah the pedagogy is
that discussion is endlessly fascinating
to me the the density question of sort
of
too much not enough too little and then
the goalie locks
for the person or uh avatar you're
trying to serve right that yep
is is something that that we could talk
about for a very long time i'd also ask
and i think this applies in some
respects right if you're trying to learn
a skill
i think it's also very helpful to apply
some constraints at least to define what
you're trying to learn
with very tight constraints so
constraints or boundaries
uh i i think there is a fetishizing of
freedom
in in a very uh
unhelpful actually
kind of debilitatingly nebulous
way among many entrepreneurs
among some creatives who view
ultimate freedom infinite choice i could
do anything at any time
as the ideal i think
although i suspect very few people have
experienced what that level of paradox
of choice
actually inflicts on a human mind
but could you could you speak to however
you want
constraints boundaries and how you or
other people have applied them actually
and
hold that just as a bookmark you've
talked about creating tension a few
different times
in your work or in your presentations in
anything that you do could you give an
example
of how you create or have created
tension and then
had that release of tension since you've
mentioned that a few different times
i i'd love to hear a real world example
then we can
zig back to constraints and boundaries
oh well let's start with a trivial
example ready
i'm ready knock knock who's there
exactly so
we didn't agree in advance to have a
back and forth that would lead to a
stupid joke
but as soon as you say who's there a
tiny sliver of tension is created which
is
why is he doing this and what's going to
make it worth it
right or calling a book purple cow
instead of how to grow your business by
becoming remarkable
because purple cow creates tension why
is this in the business section what
does this have to do with anything
it's a mystery and then the mystery is
resolved
that tension is in all form
of teaching and culture
if there is no tension just like if you
want to shoot a rubber band across the
room
you have to stretch it backwards first
and so what
i try to do when i'm building a workshop
or something like the alt mba is to say
how few minutes can i speak
to lay the groundwork enough that
tension will be created so that
people will resolve their own tension
by learning what it is i need them to
learn
and what the mistake we often make
if you know a lot and are trying to
teach someone who doesn't know a lot
is we tell them too many things and we
relieve the tension we steal the
revelation
don't steal the revelation open the door
and let them find the revelation
could you describe an example from all
nba i mean the first thing that came to
mind for me as you're describing this
in terms of not stealing the revelation
is actually the harvard
case study method at a place like our
business school they do this
other places like stanford business
school where you have
effectively these two-part modules part
one presents
a real-world historical case study of a
problem or opportunity or situation
that a business or more accurately
leaders within a business are facing and
then
cliffhanger and the class then at that
point
has to determine the proper course of
action what they think
should be done or not done and then you
have the revelation in part two where
they talk about
what was actually done and how it turned
out so
that jump to mind is an example of that
but i would imagine that is not the
format you're using
within something like the alt mba so how
do you not steal the revelation but
create tension so that people will
plow ahead with developing a skill or
learning something
it's such a cool idea to bring up the
harvard case study
the there is a reveal
sometimes in a harvard case but it is
not the revelation
and that's why it works that if you knew
the reveal
the class wouldn't go better the
revelation
in a harvard case is when a student
comes up with a an approach that they
wouldn't have had
if they hadn't heard the conversation
and that probably isn't
what the company did because it's that
furrowing around in a safe space
that lets you experience years and years
and years of
strategic business thinking in one year
because you know so like one of the most
famous cases
there was a gas chain called atlantic
ridgefield arco
and there was pages and pages of
spreadsheets
about um their credit cards
and because in the gas business when gas
was 30 cents a gallon credit cards were
a big
chunk of what they did and what it
forced
students to do who had never thought
about any of these issues
was dig in deep on where does the money
flow what's the difference between what
you charge someone and what you make
what is it like to be the low-cost
provider etc
well the reveal is that arko just
canceled all their credit cards and they
became the first
chain that was just cash only in the 70s
and 80s
but it didn't matter that that's what
they did what mattered was
30 or 60 people together were
digging into this situation
and so i didn't have any of that in mind
when i built the alt mba
and just an aside so we're up to 5 000
grads but i shouldn't say we anymore
because it's now a b corp
and it's run by marie and alex
so i've turned the reins over to them
i'm still involved in
the kimbo the b corp but i need to give
them full credit for the institution
that they were building
what i said was without the
18 pages of harvard case study what's
a nugget here so a nugget is something
like
let's talk about a decision
and tell everyone else in your cohort
a decision you made and how you used
decision thinking to make it and then
defend your decision
for the five other people you're with
and they will do the same with you
and most of us have never actually had
an emotion free conversation
about a decision that we've made because
usually we make them
either after it didn't work out or
we forget right but in this case having
to
work your way through it say well i
decided this instead of that and i did
this
instead of that suddenly without me
telling you without anybody telling you
you realize there's actually
a calculus to making almost any decision
and you glossed over the parts that you
were afraid of and now you can see them
differently
and when you add to that the persistence
of the cohort
what you end up with is this increase in
safety and enrollment which are the two
core elements of learning that will
enable you to deal with ever more
tension
which leads to more incompetence which
leads to the revelation
well so many so many different
directions we could
talk from there but we skipped over
constraints i really wanted oh no we did
we did we didn't skip i threw a
boomerang
and we're coming back to constraints so
we could talk about susan rothenberg
painted horses we could talk about
ken burns we could talk about mr rogers
if you look at
many of these iconic whether it be
television shows
movies creatives teachers who you have
described in your books and elsewhere
they are stellar examples
of the power of positive constraints
and i would just love to hear you tell a
story or two
that really stand out for you whether
it's other people
or the constraints that have been
incredibly impactful
for you personally constraints
used to frustrate me so much and now
they are
the core of my useful
working life uh i'll start with this
when i was growing up
i broke my arm and i broke my nose
playing hockey
and uh i was terrible at it but i knew
what was going on on the ice but i was
terrible at it
the thing is if you've ever tried to
play hockey on a rink that has no boards
that's just a giant lake it's a totally
different game the boards
are the point without the boards there
is no hockey
and for me i've set up constraints
all around me constraints about how i
choose which projects constraints about
what i eat constraints about
what a project can entail and what it
can't entail
constraints about how many people work
with me constraints about
uh which media i'm going to be in and
which ones i'm not going to be in
and they're all arbitrary that there
isn't
a law of nature that says don't be on
tick tock don't be on twitter but it's
okay to have a daily blog
i don't know where those rules came from
i just made up rules
because having constraints lets me get
to the edge
it lets me get to the boards without
breaking my nose
that knowing so in the case of the alt
mba
i built it in a two week period of time
in the desert in utah and i made like
seven constraints because i could have
built it in a hundred different
directions
but i made constraints about what the
dropout rate would be
what the tools we would use would be
what tools we wouldn't use
what it would cost all of those things
went in before
i started brainstorming anything because
i know that the cost of going back and
starting over
is tiny whereas the cost of making up
the constraints
after you have what you think of as a
great idea
are enormous when people
start a business or i should say rather
uh it was about to become an
illustration of what you probably don't
want to do
when someone comes to you and says i am
thinking of starting a business
how would you usher them through the
process of deciding on constraints
before they embark on creating some
darling that they're not willing to kill
or exactly yes get tied up in knots
so the core questions that we begin with
are
what resources are you willing to put
into this either resources you're
willing to
expend emotional labor and risk to get
or resources you already have
they could be resources of time and risk
tolerance
and money right number two
is who do you want your customers to be
because if you hate your customers
you're going to hate your business
and number three is what do you want to
get out of this
are you looking for something that makes
every day better or are you looking to
gruel your way through something so that
x number of months or years from now you
win a prize
notice that you don't get to reverse the
answers
to these from what you started with as
your germ of an idea
that these are not about your idea at
all
and you can always tell when an
entrepreneur is trying to
backpedal as fast as they can and say
well the idea i really want to do is
so-and-so so therefore these are my
answers
i've done that i and every time i've
done that i have been disappointed
if we can look at it with that agnostic
point of view
now we've created a puzzle and puzzles
always have constraints and boundaries
and we say all right given that this is
the puzzle
no you cannot come up with a
carbon sequestration technology that
will spread around the world and help
you dominate a new industry
when you're only willing to mortgage
your house no that's it
can't be done so you've found a a null
set
of place where your goals and your
constraints
conflict so instead let's take a deep
breath and figure out what you
really are hoping to do every day
and what success will look like when
you're done
and one specific example that i think
your listeners will really resonate with
is
freelancers if you're really a
freelancer you have no employees
you only sell your x number of hours a
week that's all you get
but if at the same time you want to make
10 million dollars a year
you're going to be unhappy because you
can't really be a sole practitioning
freelancer
who's making 10 million dollars a year
so which is it
and let's get really clear about why
you're doing this who it's for
and what's it for what do you do with
someone who has started a business
or a creative endeavor or they're a
freelancer who uh oh
now they have x number of employees and
the
the original plot has kind of escaped if
that makes any sense or
priorities and
they now want to
take the car into the shop and apply
some constraints
is there a particular approach you might
recommend to those people
who have you know they're already out of
the garage they've been driving around
they're like okay there's a problem
this needs to be fixed
[Music]
the answer could be of course just
retiring that's that's one option
uh but are there other ways that you
encourage people to explore
right constraints if if they already are
in motion with something so you've
touched on
one of the most important elements of
human nature which is our inability to
ignore sunk costs
some costs are the the unspoken
minefield of mistake
in which we rationalize why
we have to justify the thing we already
have we invent
new meanings for the word momentum well
beyond isaac newton
and we imagine that we have to stick
with what we did
so much of the time
learning to ignore sunk costs is the
single most useful thing i can point out
to people
however there are times when you
actually do have momentum when you have
trust
when you have assets when you have a
chance to go forward
and in the book i tell the story of rem
and rem
was a successful college radio band that
was gigging
hundreds of times a year but they were
not the rem of today they weren't this
famous legendary band
and they made two decisions they
invented two constraints
before they made a new album and the
constraints were
we're going to stop touring for four
months and
you'd be amazed at how few bands add
that constraint
if you saw the gogo's documentary the
go-go's
would have definitely had a half a dozen
more hit albums if they had just stopped
touring for three months when they were
all burning out
and then the second thing they did was
they switched instruments
that the guitar switched to the mandolin
and the bass player switched to the
guitar
and they said you have to play a
different instrument on this album
those two decisions ended up
creating one of the best-selling albums
of the decade because
they got all the benefits of their
momentum and their trust for each other
and the trust with the fans
but those fresh eyes and those new
boundaries enabled them to explore new
edges
and it's at the edges where the tension
lies and so they weren't playing covers
of their old selves they were something
new
so i want to talk about the practice and
there's
there's a there's a little nugget
in the elements of the practice this
list of elements
contained in the many chapters
and bits of wisdom and tactical advice
that you have in this book
one is seek joy
how does one do that well it gets back
to
uh enjoying what you do more than uh
doing what you enjoy and so the question
is
you know if marshall sallins uh who
just wrote a book with david graber who
recently passed away but marshall
sallans wrote a
breakthrough book in the 60s called
stone age economics
and it is about what it was like to be a
caveman
and it turns out the cavemen who in my
view
were wearing like these horrible
flintstones like clothes and
barely surviving only worked three hours
a day
and they spent the rest of their time
being present and alive and with their
family and all the things that people
say they want to do more of
and what's fascinating to me about that
is
lots of the people that you and i know
who go to work
and just dig it out day after day
don't do it because they need more money
they are seeking some sort of status
some sort of
emotional engagement some sort of energy
but they forget
along the way because they signed up for
this other game
that there is the game one can play of
wow
that really was cool what i just made
that fills me with joy
i just did something generous i just
connected with someone at an elemental
level
that they're too busy playing somebody
else's game to play that game
i've read in many books
that some version of we're all playing
games and step
step one is to know which game we're
playing and maybe step two is to
deliberately choose the game we're
playing as opposed to something we
absorbed or inherited or
had imposed on us by by
others or by upbringing you have
zigged quite a lot when others have
zagged
how do you think about the game or games
that you play
because these are just like hockey right
there are certain constraints
certain objectives certain values that
are given points positively or
negatively
how have you chosen the games you have
chosen
and how has that changed over time i
know that's like 15 questions in one but
i know you can handle it
it's a great question and there are a
few people i would answer it for but i'm
delighted to answer it for you it's a
great question
the first rule is you don't break your
nose
that is the first rule and what i mean
by that
is i have been surrounded
since i started one of the first
internet companies which was 1990 91
before the world wide web i have been
surrounded by people who have been
playing a game
with very few elements of scorekeeping
that generally revolve around wealth
and they will come up with all sorts of
reasons why their silicon valley
doohickey is going to change the world
for the better but
it's not really true and they will make
decisions and compromises about who they
hire and how they spend their day
because that game is culturally
sanctioned
it is a game that's truly deniable in
the milton friedman sense
and you know you're getting what
technology wants you getting what the
market wants
turn the ratchet and it has been
thrilling
every few years to be around that rush
of growth but early on
with yoyodyne i saw what it would mean
to take it to the next level and when i
got to 70 employees
i said i can't these people should not
be counting on me
and i can't play the way i like to play
on behalf of 70 other people and so i
had to stop
and then a few years later i did it
again with squidoo which was before
pinterest and all the rest
um and so what i've learned is that
veering away
from the next two zeros of upside
is really expensive and the single best
way for me to live the life i want to
live
and so i didn't write the sequel to
permission marketing and i didn't start
mailchimp and i didn't you know there's
all these things i could have done if i
was a business builder
but i'm not a business builder the game
i'm playing is
have i earned enough trust to do another
generous project that i'm proud of
and if so do i get to do it again what
other elements
of the life you wanted to live
provided for you the tipping of the
scales
like you said i mean giving up those
additional two zeros of upside
has a cost i mean there is sort of an
incremental return on dollar
right at some point like a marginal use
of each dollar
but there's a sacrifice being made what
how would you describe the life you
wanted to live that was on
the other side of door number two so you
mean the one i picked as opposed to the
one i walked away from
that's right um i was so fortunate
to have two amazing parents and um
we lived in buffalo new york not a big
town and there were always people
parading in our house one night uh at
one thanksgiving 18
russian refuseniks showed up for their
first thanksgiving all smoking like
chimneys
right the
way it felt to see them be part of the
community of their choice
and to simply commit to the work they
were doing so my mom worked
as a volunteer at the museum and then
got a job there and
pioneered the museum store and she just
stuck with it and stuck with it and
stuck with it
without a lot of drama but in terms of
it was sustaining and
she could point to work that she did
that others didn't think were gonna
make a difference that really did and
so that was my role model and i was
aware really early on
that that was sort of unique that i was
really lucky
to have that privilege and that head
start but
i have been aware that it would be
really easy to blow it
it would be really easy to say i need a
seventh house or an eighth house as
opposed to just one
and so one of the constraints was
there's enough and knowing that there's
enough
opens the door to merely do the work
whereas if you need to get attached
to the outcome because you need more now
you're not doing the work anymore
now you're just simply trading for the
outcome what's
what's so bad about trading for the
outcome is it because and i'm
i'm playing a bit of a devil's advocate
here but is it that
you ultimately cannot determine the
outcome because so much is outside of
your control is that what makes that
unappealing is it just that day-to-day
you're
kind of trading misery now for some
low probability ill-defined
happiness in the future that is probably
not going to come true
what are the main risks of of kind of
betting on outcome because that is what
a lot of people do right i mean
yeah i'm in austin but it's it's right
now as opposed to silicon valley but the
outcome-driven decision-making
is the default i would say
in the sort of individualized american
culture at least what are the
the main risks that you see that that i
haven't mentioned a couple ways to look
at this
you're exactly right that the current
western mindset is tell me if it's going
to work and then i'll do it
and part of this comes from school
which is you know you're in school if
someone says will this be on the test
the phrase will this be on the test
means i am willing to momentarily
memorize this if you are willing to
trade me for an a
and if not i'll zone out because i got
plenty of other things to do i'll be
back when you're ready to trade
uh but then let's go one more step
there's a hack need ex
there's that word there's a hackneyed
expression which is
uh what would you do if you knew you
could not fail and i find that
completely unhelpful
because it's basically a genie question
you know all right i want invisibility
and i want control over this and i want
you're never going to get those things
here's my question
what would you do if you knew you would
fail
what would be worth doing even though
it's not
gonna work and if you've got things on
that list
that you haven't been doing ironically
those are the things that are most
likely to work because other people
aren't doing them either
and this idea of attachment i mean you
know chung young trumpet rinpoche said
uh the bad news is we are following
falling following the good news is
there's nothing to hold on to and as
soon as we explore
there's nothing to hold on to then we
can get back to the work
right elizabeth king's practice that
prevents us from wondering about what
prize we're going to get this is just
the work
then you can merely do it most people
who enter the
boston marathon know they're not going
to win but they enter anyway
and that's the way i think life is
probably more like
than i will only enter the marathon if
i'm going to win it
the practice is your
what book which number by the
way i count it maybe 20 20.
why write this book
so as you and i both know writing a book
is a ridiculous venture it takes a
really long time
and then when you're done with it almost
nobody says
fantastic the way they do say if you
made a new
record because when you make a record
people go listen to it
but when you make a book they ask for a
prize because they finished reading it
and um so i only write a book when i
have no choice
and what makes me have no choice well
what i learned a really long time ago
is once i start working my way through a
set of ideas i owe those ideas something
and they owe i owe them a package and a
way for them
to come to people in a venue that i hope
will help
and the thing about a book that isn't
true for all
other forms of electric media electronic
media that are easy to share
is when you hand someone a book the
whole package is right there
and when your book group goes through a
book you get to do it together
and so yeah i made a workshop about
what's in this book
and i could have written 20 blog posts
instead of writing a book
but i wanted to signal to myself and to
other people
that this one was book worthy and
probably for the last five books
i felt like maybe i don't know when the
next book's coming after it
and this one's one of those which is if
this has to be my last book i'm proud to
make this one my last book
what should people hope to get from this
book what is the promise or premise
of the practice well the subtitle is
ship creative work
and either you do that for a living or
you don't
if you don't do that for a living good
luck to you
because you're a cog in a system that
wants to replace you
on the other hand if you ship creative
work ship means if it doesn't ship it
doesn't count
work means you do it even when you don't
feel like it and creative is where the
joy is
because creative is no one's ever done
it this way before
and here i made this and all i know
for me anyway is those moments
they're they're bathed in golden light
for me when i
feel like like i just got a shipment in
uh 10 minutes before we started talking
of the dozen collectors
packages that i designed and printed to
go with
uh this for 400 people and i'm just
holding them in my hands
and it was only three months ago but i
don't remember making them
i just remember the way it felt to make
them and
i want other people to feel that feeling
while they're serving
the people around them this is going to
seem like a complete left turn but i'm
going to
okay i'm going to try to make it more of
a
a mogul course that makes some sense
how would you suggest
people learn to juggle so
i've taught more people to juggle than
most i'm not
a great juggler but we're not talking
about
figuratively i'm talking about actually
juggling
so let's talk this too because i think
it's a useful lesson
if you have ever seen a juggler on
television or on video or in person
what you notice is that they don't drop
the ball
not dropping the ball is perhaps the
driving force of what makes someone a
juggler
and if you are enjoying the show
you are willing and wishing the balls
not to drop
so if someone says you want to learn how
to juggle you might say yes
and this is what always happens when i
teach people to juggle
they grab three balls and say no no
don't get they grab three balls
and they throw the first one the zzz
they throw the second one
and then they go to catch it because
they know catching is the key to
juggling
and by the time they get to the second
ball they have to lunge for it
and once you lunge for the second ball
you're out of position
for the third one and then you're done
it's all on the ground
and you give up on juggling because if
juggling is about catching
you're terrible at it what's the
alternative
well the way i've taught people how to
juggle is simple i give them one ball
and we spend between 20 minutes and 30
minutes throwing the ball and letting it
hit the ground
no catching then we add the second ball
throw throw
drop drop no catching throw throw drop
drop
if you do that for 40 minutes total
you're gonna be really good at throwing
and if you get
really good at throwing the catching
takes care of itself
and this is the part about divorce from
the outcome because
all we care about if we want to learn to
juggle is to learn to throw
and the metaphor i cannot escape which
is
getting better at throwing is what we
have to do to build resilience
and it's what we have to do to live in a
world that's changing ever faster
because if we try to anchor on outcomes
and control results we're in the
catching business
and then we're really in bad trouble so
to continue with this
the throwing instead of catching right
this inversion of
importance that then allows
someone to actually learn the skill they
set out to learn but doing it in a very
counter-intuitive way
the first thing i'll say is that this
reminds me a lot of
how i learned to swim in my 30s i
couldn't swim until i got into my 30s
and it was terry lachlan of total
immersion swimming may he rest in peace
passed away a few years ago who
indirectly
i suppose through his writing i learned
to i learned to swim through a
book which is just astonishing when you
think about it
because he took out the base assumptions
or he
corrected the base assumptions of
swimming namely i thought
i need to swim on top of the water and i
need to kick
which is in fact how a lot of swimming
is taught and he said
nope you're not going to do that and
you're not even going to focus on
kicking like we are not going to do
anything that will make you tired in
fact if you are tired when you're
learning how to swim you're doing it
incorrectly we're just gonna have you
kick off the side
of the shallow end of a pool and
practice getting into a fuselage
position and
the sequence even though in retrospect
it makes perfect sense was
so different from any other attempt
that i that that i had made through
books videos instruction coaching you
name it
it just worked and it blew my mind and
now i
swim i mean i have my swimming gear with
me today to go swimming for
relaxation which i never thought in a
million years would be the case i never
i'm not going to let you ask your
question yet i have to interject here
i never knew this about you i swim his
method
every single day and i knew how to swim
but the year i was at stanford they had
a master's class at the stanford pool
and i couldn't resist i went and
this guy comes out to teach it he's the
consultant to the u.s olympic swim team
and he's assisted by the coach of the
stanford swim team
his name's bill boomer bill
had a very significant pot belly
and one arm and i'm like this guy is
going to teach us how to swim
and the beauty of it was it's
all about the process and not about the
outcome
because you don't get good at the
outcome for a long time and the second
part when we were talking about
incompetence before
what you didn't mention is learning to
swim terry's way
involves drowning for at least an hour
and a half
and that's why most people don't get to
the other side
just to be clear it is an
uncomfortable practice by design there
is
if done correctly no risk there's a
physical
risk involved if you're doing it with
supervision uh and he will do
also things like remove breathing right
in the sense
that you are not swimming and learning
how to breathe at the same time it's
just too much
right it's like giving being given a
unicycle and seven balls to juggle it's
like that's just not gonna work for the
vast majority of folks
and so he says all right great well
let's take the breathing out of it at
that failure point will be removed let's
take out the breathing we're just going
to focus on hydrodynamics and teaching
you that
naturally because of the density of your
body you're going to be 70 plus percent
underwater when you swim period full
stop you're not a hydrofoil and
you gave then uh what i think is
in some respects a comparable example
of a logical but counterintuitive
progression
with the learning to throw instead of
catch
if someone were to ask you
how would you teach someone to be
creative and i'm asking that
in in a deliberately maybe problematic
way but
what would your answer be if they were
like great i get the swimming example
i get the juggling example i want to be
more creative
what's the equivalent for becoming more
creative what would you say
it's exactly the same and i've done it
many many times
here you go if you want to learn how to
juggle you have to drop an enormous
number of balls
if you want to learn how to swim you
have to sort of drown
and if you want to learn to be creative
you have to show me an enormous number
of bad ideas
pick the smallest region domain
any segment you want start listing your
bad ideas
keep listing your bad ideas let's prove
that your bad ideas are not fatal that's
part one
part two domain knowledge and genre
it is true that every once in a while an
outsider shows up with something
that nobody on the inside ever thought
of but that's not usually what happens
what usually happens is someone who has
good
taste decides to be willing to be
creative
and good taste means you know what your
audience wants
10 minutes before they do that's all
you can't have good taste unless you
have domain knowledge and understand
genre
so if you combine those two things
shipping on the regular
and good taste you can be creative
when you say genre what do you mean
because this is a if someone is accused
of and i use that word very deliberately
being a genre writer or a
genre of this genre it can be used in a
derisive way sure
what what do you mean by genre and
how would you prefer people to
understand genre
so um generic and genre are not
being used by me in the same way genre
means what am i expecting
when i encounter your work so earl
stanley gardner wrote mystery novels
and they fit neatly into the genre of
mystery novels we knew which section of
the bookstore to put them in
but they were nothing like agatha
christie novels
and earl stanley gardner sold a quarter
of a billion books
by writing his own distinct
idiosyncratic
peculiar particular books that clearly
were in
a genre can i just say for a second i
apologize
you were talking about how 99 of the
people in the united states haven't read
your books
i am constantly both amazed and
not surprised at all that you just
mentioned someone who sold a quarter
billion
books and i have no idea who this person
is may i hum a few bars
yeah donna
don't know
amazing and he wrote uh he had a
secretary who was a little like dela
street
della i don't know what her name was his
secretary had a yellow legal pad
earl dictated the books while she
followed him around
didn't edit a word every two weeks he
had a new one
wow it's kind of yeah well it's like
james the the james patterson machine
right yeah or james bond it goes with
the word james apparently but
the thing about genre is we don't know
what to do
with a creative idea that doesn't rhyme
with anything else right so
is google a creative innovation after
the world had seen yahoo
well of course it is because marissa and
the rest said let's not have 183 links
on the home page
let's have two the search results
themselves
weren't that different for years but
the leap was you know what a search
engine is this is just like that search
engine
except it's different but if they hadn't
seen yahoo and alta vista
they never could have built google and
we wouldn't have known what to do with
it
if we hadn't seen a search engine and so
what genre says is there's a box and i
can't think
outside the box because it's dark but on
the edges of the box i have leverage
you got to know what the box is before
you can make a thing that is going to be
seen as creative
if we look at the contents
of the practice there's a lot there's a
lot here
two hundred and thirty
chapters and the books less than 230
pages long yes
right so 230 chapters and i'm looking at
a partial list and i wonder which of
these
you hope people will pay particular
attention to because they
are mother qualities of a sense
and what i mean by that is i can't
recall the attribution so i won't
try to make it up on the spot but i've
heard in different forms
you know courage is the sort of mother
virtue of all virtues because at the
breaking point at the testing point
without
courage none of those virtues can be
enacted something along those lines
i like that yeah are there any
particular
chapters or qualities principles that
you really hope
people will pay particular attention to
that
if not act as prerequisites in some
fashion help
the others so one of the reasons that
this needs to be a book
or a workshop that lasts 150 days
is we're so complicated everyone's come
up
with their own combination of what's
holding them back
and the way to unlock it i wish there
was a hierarchy in a taxonomy
that said this is how we get all the way
up to the top
i don't feel like it's maslow being in
that way
i feel like we each find our own
sinicure our own way to hide out
from the thing that is keeping us from
the creativity that we want to deliver
and it starts to eat us up inside and
that
the deeper we've built it
the harder it is for us to have an
outsider help us the
list of excuses we have is infinite and
so i don't know if i could point to this
one which unlocks all of them i guess
the juggling one has a big piece of it
which is throwing
not catching and i think the generosity
one
which is i'm not throwing for myself i
am throwing for other people
when i add those two up what i end up
with is this
creativity is a generous act get out of
your own way
don't ask for a guarantee simply
merely ship the work without drama and
without dialogue
which is the opposite it would seem
please correct me if wrong of a word you
just used that i did not know the
definition to because i
therefore had to look it up sinicure and
say any
c-u-r-e noun a position requiring little
or no work but giving the holder
status or financial benefit from the
latin
cine cura cuda without care
so rather than do that you're
effectively it would seem like going to
the opposite end of the spectrum
is that fair to say although
status or financial benefit could come
along with it but it is
a very different combination of things
that you're suggesting
so let's go back to joni mitchell
because something happened to joni
mitchell after
i don't know which album number and it
was
that she was unstoppable that her albums
were on every radio station and were
in every college dorm room and joni
was in danger of becoming a hack because
the audience knew exactly what they
wanted from a joni mitchell record
and exactly what they wanted from a joni
mitchell concert
and johnny mitchell looked at that and
she said i'm whatever 30 years old
i could do this quite profitably for the
next 40 years it's a sinicure
that she will be beloved and she will
never fail because writing another joni
mitchell song was pretty easy for her
and so she made a record called don
juan's reckless daughter
and then she made a couple other ones
after that
that seemed intentionally designed
to alienate her audience but they
weren't
they were intentionally designed to
alienate the old
joni mitchell's audience so that she
could find her smallest viable audience
and make the music she wanted to for
them
because her goal wasn't to sell more
records
her goal was to explore that golden
place
of wow this might not work but if she
kept making the things that would work
she would ruin her life and i just
i'll listen to that record god must be a
boogeyman with jaco pistorius
on the fretless bass and there's still
songs in there i don't get yet
but i'm so proud of her to have said
enough i have enough now how do i make
better
what would you do even if you knew you
would fail
i love that i love that recasting
of the question that i've always enjoyed
but uh for
any number of reasons very often not
come up with great answers to
what would you do if you knew you could
not fail
the even if you knew you would fail in a
sense i mean it's
of course there's some caveats to the
question in a sense but if you answer
this or pursue the answers
explore the answers to that question you
also
end up doing things for which you will
have
a it will be natural i was about to say
unnatural but an
uncommon endurance or attachment
which will then increase the likelihood
that over time you will have some
version of success i mean it seems that
way to me at least
and if you don't then you've chosen in
such a way that at least the path
along the way has some has some nice
scenery so you're just not
you know a horse in times square with
blinders on going around in circles
well said seth you're
always so fun to chat with
i enjoy our conversations immensely i've
taken a bunch of notes
for myself people can find
you at seth's dot blog i can find you on
twitter instagram
at this is sethblog on twitter instagram
seth godan i'll link to everything
including the new book the practice
subtitle shipping creative work in the
show notes at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast is there anything else you would
like to
say any recommendations requests
comments complaints anything that you'd
like to put in front of the listeners
before we wrap up i would because uh you
gave me the last word
which is it's easy to forget
how hard you tim have worked
at leading illuminating and pushing
yourself
to become different better versions and
you show up on the regular and share it
and i for one am grateful you do
thank you very much seth i really
appreciate you saying that needed that
today that's a longer story
but i i really appreciate you saying
that and
hope to see you again soon but in the
meantime thank you for
taking the time today to share
your life your learnings and the
importance of the practice
i really appreciate it thanks we'll see
you here
and to everybody else until next time
thank you for listening hey guys this is
tim again just a few more things before
you take off
number one this is five bullet friday do
you want to get
a short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
tonal t-o-n-a-l i'm super excited about
this one
and i was skeptical of it in the
beginning tonal
quote total is the world's most
intelligent home gym and personal
trainer end quote that's the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space tonal
is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to tonal by three different
friends all of them are tech savvy
one of them is a former competitive
skier who's doubled his strength in a
number of movements using total even
though he has a
long athletic background and i'll paint
a picture for you by eliminating
traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells total can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more of the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal
you can dial weights up and down with
the touch of a button in one pound
increments using magnets and electricity
so the movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm still
getting a tonal installed i've used
tonal for multiple workouts now
to do things i just cannot do in my home
gym
such as the chop and lift exercises from
4-hour body all sorts of cable exercises
that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then total
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that the other thing and
after one workout on total focusing on
pulling i was blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
total also has a growing library of
expert led workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized to your body
using artificial intelligence and other
aspects
of the engineering and smart features
check your form in real time just like a
personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but try tonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www dot dot
for 100 off of smart accessories when
you use promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim tonal be your strongest
this episode is brought to you by
pornhub
just kidding this episode is brought to
you by four sigmatic
which is part of my morning routine also
part of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are
a number of ways that i use for sigmatic
in the mornings
i regularly start with their mushroom
coffee instead of regular coffee
and it doesn't taste like mushroom let
me explain this first of all
zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee
it's easy on my stomach tastes amazing
and all you have to do
is add hot water i use travel packets
i've been to probably a dozen countries
with various products from four sigmatic
and their mushroom coffee is top of the
list
that's number one i travel with it i
recommend it i give it to my employees
i give it to house guests so if you're
one of the 60 percent of americans or
more who drink coffee daily
consider switching it up this stuff is
amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive enhancement side
easy on the system side energizing side
the next is actually their chaga tea
which
tastes delicious it is decaf
completely decaf and some may recognize
chaga
it is nicknamed the king of the
mushrooms it is excellent for immune
system
support so needless to say i'm focused
on that
right now myself and so i will often
have that
in the afternoons they make all sorts of
different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself sane
cordyceps excellent for endurance they
have a whole slew of options
you can check out every single batch is
third party lab tested for heavy metals
allergens all the bad stuff
to make sure that what gets into your
hands is what you want to put in your
mouth and they always offer a 100
money back guarantee so you can try it
risk free why not
i've worked out an exclusive offer with
four sigmatic on their best-selling
lions main coffee i literally have a mug
full of it in front of me right now
and this is just for you my dear podcast
listeners receive up to 39
off i don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39
off it's a lot they're best-selling
lions main coffee bundles to claim this
deal you must go to 4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available on
their regular website go to four
sigmatic that's f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com slash tim to get yourself some
awesome and delicious mushroom
coffee full discount is applied at
[Applause]
checkout